stephen  what are you sure you want to know  we deliver justice  i like the sound of that  i'm really chased about showing you  these new skill sets i have  am i like some sort of secret agent  it's a little more complicated than that  marvel studios moon night only on disney  plus when you look past the surface what  do you see  complicated man  battling an inner conflict struggling  for balance  am i like some sort of secret  it's  agent  little more complicated than that  [Music]  force of strength  wondering what the hell is happening  around her stephen  a mysterious figure worshiped exalted  and you don't want to come face to face  with his unworldly power  [Music]  marvel's moon night is coming to disney  plus  trust me  he's the one you'll see coming  [Music]  you